for me when I hear british council thing
that coming to my mind is a place where
you go to acquire knowledge the British
Council has decades of relationships
within the countries that they work the
British Council is able to bring in the
expertise that have succeeded in many
other countries the people I've worked
with the British Council have been
amazing in understanding how we work as
a private sector entity I see every what
you think Microsoft and the British
Council teamed up because we have very
similar philosophies we believe strongly
in helping teach 21st century skills
through the use of ICT in classrooms
as to how the ballast come
the British Council out great contacts
great relations with governments with
NGOs and therefore they know everybody
and can get things done premier skills
is a program where we teach people how
to coach football in the disadvantaged
areas so reach the numbers of people
who've reached and to have the success
we've had who have been absolutely
impossible that the British Council
the British Council realizes that a man
is focusing on promoting literacy they
become the middle entity between
government and the private sector when
they came up with kids read we welcomed
it the British Council is linked into
cultural and educational aspects of
local government programs that HSBC
wouldn't necessarily be linked into the
wider aims are our social programs
really is to ensure that those computers
advantage backgrounds have access to
education really it's a win-win
situation the British Council has a
great deal of strength in business to
government a business to academia and
therefore putting the two organizations
together allows us to access those
relationships the idea is a competition
for young eco entrepreneurs hell are you
avin the British Council were able to
work together to show that to British
organizations are acting globally to
improve sustainability
tullow oil and the British Council are
looking for young people with potential
to make a difference in the oil and gas
industry we have a very important
scholarship scheme in very safe and
trusted hands
if these young boys and girls are going
to transit from Ghana to UK they need a
company that has been working already in
this knowledge base the hakuna have
identified any other entity a certain
British guns
I haven't run into another organization
around the world quite like British
Council working with the British Council
has been very instructive very proud of
what we've achieved
the British Council are a fantastic
organisation
and